En un video previo, aprendimos acerca de la forma
desarrollada de un número, a escribir un número
como 832 -que tiene 8 centenas, 3 decenas y
2 unidades-, como 800 + 30 + 2, 8 centenas,
más 3 decenas, más 2 unidades; y vimos otros
ejemplos de esto mismo. En este video vamos a ver
cómo pasar de la forma escrita de un número a su
forma desarrollada. Veamos un ejemplo. Imagina que
queremos escribir el siguiente número en su forma
desarrollada. No voy a decirlo en voz alta porque
quiero que lo trabajes por tu cuenta. Así que
tenemos este número que estoy escribiendo. ¿Por
qué no pausas el video e intentas ver si puedes
escribir este número en su forma desarrollada?
Bien, primero veamos cuántas centenas
tenemos. Bueno, nos dicen 700, justo aquí:
entonces estas son 7 centenas, así que vamos
a escribirlo: 700. Después nos dicen 41;
bueno, 40 y 1 es una combinación de cierto
número de decenas y cierto número de unidades:
41 es lo mismo que 40 + 1, así que ¿por qué
no lo escribimos de esta forma? La parte que
dice 40 podemos escribirla así: + 40, y después
sumaremos 1, + 1. Y ya está listo. Teníamos 741
escrito con letra, es decir, en su forma escrita,
y logramos pasarlo a su forma desarrollada.